lo que ve representado aquí se le conoce
como pedigrí el pedigrí es una forma de
analizar el patrón de la herencia de los
rasgos dentro de una familia este puede
ser útil para entender más acerca de sus
rasgos tal vez para generar algunas
ideas sobre la genética de ese rasgo y
es una forma de pensar que sucedió en el
pasado de esa familia y con ello obtener
ciertas probabilidades o algún mejor
entendimiento de lo que puede pasarle en
el futuro
ahora vamos a separar toda esta
información para entender todas las
partes distintas del pedigrí en esta
imagen un círculo representa un miembro
femenino de la familia mientras que un
cuadrado representa a un miembro
masculino si el cuadrado o el círculo
están coloreados como podemos ver aquí o
acá eso significa que esa persona exhibe
el rasgo de interés en este caso de
pedigrí en particular el rasgo de
interés será la presencia de pecas y si
están o no están coloreados estamos
hablando del fenotipo es decir tenemos
un rasgo observado simplemente puedes
ver a la persona y decir si tiene pecas
o no
este hombre de arriba no tiene pecas la
mujer de la derecha si tiene pecas abajo
tenemos un hombre con pecas etcétera una
vez más este es el fenotipo es decir las
características o rasgos observados sólo
con esta información no sabemos con
exactitud del genotipo aunque podríamos
inferir algunas ideas sobre el genotipo
al ver cómo se propagan los patrones del
fenotipo de generación en generación
sin embargo regresemos para entender un
poco más el pedigrí por sí misma cuando
tengamos una línea horizontal como están
conectando a un hombre con una mujer se
le conocerá como la línea de matrimonio
o línea de cruzar lo que significa que
entre ellos se acoplan y se reproducen
no necesariamente tienen que estar
casados la idea va más a la reproducción
entonces este hombre y esta mujer se
reproducen está línea vertical que baja
de la línea horizontal se le conoce como
la línea de la descendencia
es por ello que va de la primera
generación a la segunda generación por
lo tanto todos los individuos que estén
conectados con esta línea vertical al
final de la recta vertical todos ellos
son sus hijos todos los individuos
conectados directamente con esta línea
vertical y ésta se conoce como una línea
de hermandad por lo tanto este individuo
este otro y este todos son hermanos y
hermanas podemos ver que esta generación
1 tuvo dos hijas de las cuales una de
ellas exhibe pecas y un hijo que también
tiene pecas ahora todos estos otros
individuos de la generación 2 no son
hijos de la primera generación realmente
son personas que se añaden a la familia
ya sea que ellos se casaron y se
añadieron a la familia o podemos decir
con mejor esta actitud que se
reprodujeron con los miembros de la
segunda generación esto es lo que pasa
con la segunda generación así que puedes
ver que aquí también tenemos una línea
de matrimonio
dicho de cruz a una línea de
descendencia y en este caso ellos
tuvieron dos hijas así que resulta que
las pecas se vuelven un rasgo autosómico
dominante déjame apuntarlo rasgo
autosómico dominante autosómico
significa que es un rasgo asociado a un
cromosoma no sexual los seres humanos
tenemos 23 pares de cromosomas y uno de
ellos determina nuestro sexo y los demás
no lo determinan esto quiere decir que
las pecas están asociadas con uno de los
22 pares restantes de cromosomas que no
determinarán tu sexo por su parte
dominante es una de las dos versiones de
un gen una de tu padre y otra de tu
madre y cada una de esas versiones del
género que dicen si tendrás pecas o
nombre se llaman alelos pero si el rasgo
es autosómico dominante significa que si
tienes al menos un alelo para ese rasgo
entonces lo exhibidas
ahora bien f mayúscula es tener pecas
como es dominante lo escribimos en
mayúsculas y si no tienes pecas entonces
lo escribimos en minúsculas ya que es
recesivo entonces un genotipo f
mayúscula f mayúscula o f mayúscula efe
minúscula o efe minúscula f mayúscula si
quieres pensar en el orden dependiendo
de qué padre te del gen bueno en todas
estas situaciones se exhibirán el
fenotipo de pecas y ya hemos hablado de
fenotipo y genotipo en otros vídeos y
claro el único fenotipo que no exhibirá
pecas será el caso de efe minúscula
efe minúscula cuando ambos genes son
recesivos ahora teniendo todo esto en
mente que podemos inferir del genotipo
de este individuo de aquí muchas veces
nos referimos a este individuo como el
individuo 12 es decir generación 1 y
segundo individuo de esa generación
bueno sabemos que escribe pecas por lo
tanto estamos seguros de que si exhibe
pecas su genotipo es uno de estos tres
escenarios y estos dos son francamente
equivalentes por lo tanto sabemos que
esta persona tiene un genotipo que es f
mayúscula f mayúscula es decir un amor
cigoto dominante of f mayúscula efe
minúscula que es un heterocigotos bueno
pensemos primero en la situación en que
tenemos un homo cigoto dominante si
fuera un cigoto dominante entonces cada
uno de sus hijos tendría uno de estos
alelos y ambos son dominantes eso
significa que si éste fuera el caso
entonces todos los hijos tendrían pecas
pero podemos ver que eso no es cierto
dos de estos tres hijos tienen pecas y
la otra no por lo tanto podemos estar
seguros de que este no es el caso eso
quiere decir que este individuo de aquí
debe de ser un heterocigotos para las
pecas por lo tanto tendría que ser f
mayúscula
efe minúscula
y qué podemos decir de este individuo de
aquí es decir de la persona que se cruzó
con ella bueno él no exhibe el fenotipo
para las pecas por lo tanto él debe ser
efe minúscula efe minúscula de todo esto
podemos ir encontrando más información
de hecho eso lo haremos en vídeos
futuros con algunos ejemplos nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo